Voltron is about unity, about assembling
parts into something greater, but who
said all the parts have to be yours? You
provide the commander, I'll provide the
pump and evasion, and together we can
take down our common opponents. Terms
and conditions apply. Alliance valid
until the other two players are
eliminated. After that, all bets are
off. Side effects may include salt and
lifelong trust issues. Hello, this is
Chin with Next Level Commander.
Honestly, with the new Universes Beyond
designs, I haven't been entirely happy
with their flavor and top-down designs.
Like with some of these cards, I'm not
sure how much thought they put into
matching the characters and the art and
flavor and all that. But the one they
did nail is this Loki, God of Lies.
"Whenever you cast a spell that targets
only a single creature, gain control of
that creature until the end of turn. If
it's your turn, untap that creature and
it gains haste until the end of turn."
Every targeted spell becomes temporary
theft. Even with the limitation of
mono-red, there's so much you can do
with this ability. And it's more than
just theft. The deeper I dug into the
interactions, the more I was amused, and
I'm sure you will be as well. Let's take
a look. Well, starting off, we need
targeting spells, and we narrowed it
down to a few utilities that we
prioritized over others. To begin with,
we have card draw. Being able to cantrip
is just massive. It means we can just
use it for value, steal some attack
triggers, link some life, get a blocker
at instant speed, so our opponents know
that's something they will have to play
around for the rest of the game. Sticky
Fingers is a really interesting one I
found. With that, we get to steal
something, attack with the evasion, get
a treasure, and then with a side goblin,
we can cash in on that card immediately,
all for one mana. And another
interesting one is Enrage Epiphany.
Deals X damage, yada yada, that part is
not relevant. The relevant part is we
can use zero for X and it still targets
something. We steal it, we attack, and
then we sacrifice it. It still triggers
the next part of the ability, which
allows us to dig for another card to
use. I'm also looking at the impulse
draw effects. Now, these are not
amazing, but the pump is something we
need. Cuz if you think I was joking, I
wasn't. Our win condition is actually
sending opponents' commanders into
themselves. It's not the only plan, but
it's the funniest and probably the most
efficient given the tools we have. I
mean, if our table looks like this, I
will have to come up with something
else. Maybe Loki will have to do it
himself, but usually not. So, the pump
spells. The aforementioned Haze Magic
and Blazing crescendo, also titan
strength and cunning maneuver. The most
interesting one here is siege smash.
It's got split second. It might not seem
obvious, but playing with this a few
times you will see how relevant split
second is when attached to an instant
speed stealing spell. But these are just
warm up. Sometimes you need more, but
ideally we want to kill one opponent per
attack. And that's made possible by
these doubling spells. And they all come
with something interesting. Can trip,
cycling, and ball cup is sweet. You can
use it twice. So when you have enough
mana, this card alone can come pretty
close to one shotting an opponent. And
finally, spectacular showdown is pretty
average in its base form, but the
overload ability is ridiculous. With the
right board state, you will just watch
your opponents kill each other. If you
think of Loki as a video game character,
spectacular showdown would be the
ultimate. And aside from the
aforementioned, there's one last
category that we value is reusability.
Crown of flames, key to fire breathing,
and escape velocity. These cards are
amazing because they're a bit expensive
in different ways, but once you draw
them, you know you will have gas for the
rest of the game. You will always have
something to do. Okay, so now we
established that we have lots of
targeting spells and we can steal
things, sorcery speed, instant speed,
whenever. And also keep in mind that the
ability does untap the creature. So in a
pinch, we can use these spells to untap
something. And that brings us to the
utilities package. There's some pretty
spicy stuff here starting with long
shot. Now this might be the most boring
one, but this card is broken. I mean,
look at this. It's non-creature spells.
So that includes artifacts, mana rocks,
everything. These auras that we can
loop, key to fire breathing, crown of
flames. That's a lot of damage. And even
just with regular spell casting, it
definitely adds up. And we are just
getting started. Next up we have
Kiki-Jiki, Mirror Breaker. Now imagine
this and a handful of targeting spells.
Stealing this, this, and this now turns
into taking the best thing on board and
copying it. And not just once, cuz every
time we target Kiki-Jiki, it will untap.
Or we can just skip the middleman and
Splinter Twin. Doesn't say enchant
creature you control, so you can target
something, get it now, and make as many
copies as you have targeting spells in
your hand. Rionya does something
similar. Cast a few spells, steal the
creatures, make copies of the biggest
one. That That's a game-winning turn,
right? And finally, Karark, the
Thumbless. That works in a lot of decks,
and it does work here cuz Loki only
cares about targeting, not resolving.
So, potentially, every spell we can use
twice or more. You can turn a hand with
three spells into insurrection,
basically. And finally, a Sack Outlet
and Goblin Bombardment open to turn the
steal into permanent removal. Okay, so
those are some utilities synergies. But
to finish the game, we also have some
pretty cool interactions. Breath of Fury
is one of my favorite cards that I never
get to play. Now, it's not perfect here
because we can't target another
creature. We have to target something we
stole. But then, we can steal a few more
creatures and move Breath of Fury onto
each of them for an extra combat until
the creatures or our opponents are all
dead. That's pretty hardcore. Grim
Reaper's Sprint is kind of similar.
Often times, it only costs two mana, but
what we get to do is steal some things,
attack, and then cast this to steal one
more creature to pump my entire board
and get another combat. A different way
to win the game is with these two
enchantments. Let's take a look at
Elemental Mastery. We steal the biggest
creature on board, tap it for a bunch of
tokens. Now, use a pump spell to untap
it, tap for more tokens again and again.
We can swarm our opponents. Or
similarly, Burning Anger. Take the
biggest creature on board, shoot someone
for nine damage, and then 18, and after
that, another 21. I know these two are
not the most efficient, but it's going
to be so fun to do. What is efficient,
though? Jeska, Thrice Reborn. Find the
right window, use a pump spell to steal
a commander, and Jeska Someone will be
dead. Insurrection is kind of boring,
but it does make sense and fits our deck
well. And of course, if you've seen my
other videos, you know what's coming.
Giggling Skitterspike. Usually, you want
to drop it and then monsters it and then
chain a bunch of target spells onto it.
But with Loki, you can also just give it
haste with any targeting spell to get
both a target trigger and an attack
trigger immediately. And that rounds out
the spice. We do need some generic
utility. Like again, card draw will be
difficult in mono red, so we have to do
something about that. Skullclamp is
easy. We steal a creature, we clamp it,
we attack and then sacrifice. That seems
perfect in this deck. Calling Dayus is a
bit of a pet card, but it's done well
every time I played it, so it seems fine
here. Humble Defector is super
interesting. There's a lot of things you
can do with this. You can either just do
it the regular way, you know, pass it to
someone, hopefully they pass it back.
Now, if they don't, you can always steal
it on your turn, draw two cards and pass
it to another person, or just a simple
tap and sacrifice. That's okay. Or just
keep targeting it, draw two, draw two,
draw two, turn every target spell in
your hand into pot of greed. That seems
okay. I'm usually very careful with
playing wheels because it can often help
your opponents if they do deplete their
hands fast or they use their graveyards.
But here it kind of makes sense cuz you
want your opponents to drop things that
for you to steal. And if they don't,
they lose the cards. And again, mono
red, yeah, again, I I want better
options, but right now I think we have
to try these. For ramp, we have the
generic package. I wonder what the red
infinity stone does. These red mana
rocks are interesting. Low key scepter
makes a lot of sense here, and tablet of
discovery is actually very pushed. The
fact that you can play anything milled,
including lands, is really good. We are
kind of short on sac outlets. We're
relying on our lands a lot, so we have
the world map and expedition map. Throne
of Eldraine makes sense here, and a
little bit spicier is the chromatic
orrery. This is super greedy, but when
it works, it's sweet. Magical Christmas
land here is to steal a three-color or a
five-color commander and draw a bunch of
cards. That's the dream. Among the storm
mana enablers, I chose Urza because it
counts every spell. And the backside is
very underrated. This card is just
really good. I mean, she provides mana
when we have cards and provides cards
when we don't. Finally, Mana Geyser I'm
a bit iffy about. Sure, you always
remember it making 15, 20 mana, but most
of the time it's a ritual for five, so
it turns five mana into 10, which is
still decent. The reason I included is
because sure, we have our little tricks,
our combat shenanigans, but to win the
game, we will need those big turns and
Man-o'-War Geyser powers that. Okay, and
the deck is very meta-dependent, but
unfortunately, we don't have too much
room for protection, so this might be a
potential risk, but red doesn't have too
many good options to begin with. We have
Deflecting Swat, Redirect Lightning,
Lightning Greaves, and then we had to
get creative. For example, Silver Shroud
Costume. Yeah, it's a great protection
spell, but also sometimes it will be an
evasion when we steal a commander. Now,
this doesn't steal the commander itself,
but you can just drop it onto the
creature and now it's unblockable. Just
make sure you get the protection spells
onto the creature before shroud kicks
in. Finally, Veilstone Amulet. Every
time I cast a spell, my creatures get
hexproof. Yeah, so all of our targeting
spells, all of our instants become
protection spells. Oh, yeah, and
removals. We don't have too much room,
but we There will be board states where
we cannot deal with simply by stealing
things, so we have a few panic buttons.
My favorite one here though is Wild
Magic Search cuz with this, if you
target a creature, by the time it dies,
it will be stolen onto your side. So, it
dies, then you're the person who flips.
And we do have a pretty solid creature
collection, so every one of those is
worth flipping into. Okay, and that's
all of our nonlands. For lands, we need
sack outlets. Yeah, every single sack
outlet we can find. The most interesting
one here is City of Shadows. It's It's
just kind of fun.
I'm not sure if it's good.
Because first of all, it doesn't tap for
mana. You need to sack something, so if
you draw it in the early game, it's not
really a land. And also, it exhausts the
creature immediately, so no Skull Clamp
triggers, no dying triggers. So, be
careful with that, but it's It's got
potential, right? You sack a few times,
now it's tapping for three mana. Aside
from that, Arcane Lighthouse is very
important here because if your
opponent's commander is big and
powerful, it's likely protected. The
lighthouse helps us get around that. The
MDFCs are always good, and these ones
target. Oh, and Witch's Clinic because
we are Voltron-ing other people's
commanders, and this works on any
commander. So, we can dream of the
magical Christmas land. And just some
other miscellaneous utility, graveyard
hate, protection, token making, oh, and
a backup win condition. Not a super
reliable one cuz we don't pump that
heavily, unlike a lot of our other
decks. So, but it is nice to have. And
that's the deck. So, the game plan is to
play conservative early. Low key is
really good at controlling combat. With
this and some mana up, your opponents
are usually pretty scared to attack into
you. They have to look at what's on the
board. Interestingly, it doesn't untap
the creature if it's not your turn. So,
the defense play only works if there are
untapped large creatures on the board.
So, keep that in mind. But, you also
have a lot of combat tricks. So, Low Key
can get to work and do some defending, I
guess. And in the midgame, we can do our
shenanigans. We can have big turns, take
away blockers, attack for a bunch. And
that's where we can have these
mind-blowing plays. The deck is not
explosive. It's pretty slow. It's got a
decent amount of ramp, but we don't have
too much to do in the early game. I
mean, we can defend ourselves kind of
okay, but we won't be posing a threat
anytime soon. The deck is also not super
resilient. The biggest weakness is that
we do rely on the commander, but we
don't have a lot of protection for him.
So, we're leaving some of that to fate.
And like a typical red deck, we burn
bright, but we also don't have the best
battery life. Because of that, it's not
an easy deck to play. Figuring out the
interactions and synergies is just one
thing, but also we have to use our
resources cleverly, find the right
timing for everything. And it's not
super cheap to build because in
monocolor, especially mono red, that's
where the budget can make a big
difference. Oh, boy, this deck is
looking like crap.
Now, I got to be transparent. But, maybe
I should add a fun category for for my
decks. Like this deck is a blast to
play, and that's kind of why I'm
building it. But then, every deck I
make, I'm going to rate extra fun, so no
point doing that. But, this deck will be
fun, I promise. Give it a shot. Maybe
proxy it first. And this deck should be
a bracket two. I don't think it's going
to get there in bracket I mean, in
bracket three, you can steal wins, of
course, but just overall, the speed, the
consistency, I don't think it's good
enough for bracket three, but again,
your mileage may vary. And that's the
video. If you like what I'm doing,
please check out my sponsor,
KakapopoTCG,
and use my affiliate link affil- No, I
don't have a link. Affiliate code, yes.
Levels, all caps, for some sweet magic
accessories. Either way, I will see you
in the next video.